جوائز تيلا العالميه قناه العربيه حصدت 38
جائزه بينها خمس جوائز عن الفئه الذهبيه
الفئات التي فازت بها العربيه البرامج
الثقافيه والتاريخيه التصميم الابداعي
الوثائقيه السوشيال ميديا استخدام تقنيه
الواقع المعزز
منها تغطيه الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه
تقارير زلزال سوريا وتركيا الميزانيه
السعوديه لعام 2023
تغطيه كاس العالم
من البرامج الساعه 60
العربيه 360
عسكري تاريا
مهمه خاصه
على خطى العرب
روافد
سؤال مباشر الندوه
البعد الاخر
وثائقيات ريان اثر الفراشه
سوشيال ميديا حكايه على العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات